[Music]
hello everyone my name is Reina Montanez
Khan and I'm on a developer advocate at
Google so in the last few months
together with three of my colleagues
we've been working on bringing plants
back in fashion so more precisely plan
is an application that was initially
developed by my colleague Nick butcher
as a way of showcasing material design
and what you see here is actually the
state of the app in 2016 when was pretty
much as iPods glory days so Nick used
here a lot of the API is from the
animations transitions animated vector
drawables so all of these really made
the app shine they really improved the
user experience
so what integrates data from three
different sources and well these sources
from 2016 until now well some of them
were deprecated so that meant that out
of three sources we were left with one
and a little bit so from all these nice
fancy UI features that we had well we
were left with almost nothing we were
left with a pretty boring application
somebody aside we didn't wanna leave it
like this and we said that we wanted to
fix this broken functionality but apart
from this we also knew that we wanted to
go towards something that's modular and
extensible from the architecture point
of view but the thing is that plant was
developed as a UI sample not not as an
architecture sample so you won't be
surprised to see all the tied
dependencies in the in the code and well
code that was actually a bit behind
because Nick started building this in
2014 at that time we didn't had the guy
to help architects sure that we released
last year and also although we have
caught him we didn't really use it so we
knew that I wanted to rebuild plants but
we wanted to rebuild it in the right way
to have it in a good state for any
future changes that we wanted to build
so in this talk I want to tell you what
we've
and also how we were managed how we
managed to leverage causing in our app
so we release this opinionated guy to
the of architecture but if you read it
you'll see that it's also still quite
vague so we have these like main classes
some idea of how we should architect our
app but we decided we want to create
some clear guidelines so we defined some
main types of classes in our app and we
also define a set of rules for each of
these classes so let's see which ones
these were so we define a remote data
source whose role is actually to just
construct the request data fetch the
data from the from the API service and
that's it if it only request the
information and return the response
received next we would have a local data
source whose role is just to store data
on this so it would either do this and
share preferences or in the database
next I would have the repository whose
role is to fetch ants and store data and
optionally it could also do in-memory
cache so the repository will be the
class that mediates between the local
and the remote data source because the
business logic was quite complex we
decided to add another layer we decided
to add use cases so the role of the use
cases is just to process data based on
business logic this would be small
lightweight classes that could be also
reused so the use cases with depend on
repositories and or other use cases next
we would have a view model so the view
models role is to expose data to be
displayed by the UI and also to trigger
actions based on the user's actions and
the view model would depend on use cases
as an input the view model would get
maybe IDs so it would get IDs in the
case where it's a view model for a
detailed screen for example and of
course it would get the user actions as
an input and as an output it would
return a live data next in the UI we
would work with activities and examine
so the role of these is to just display
the data and to forward actions to the
view model as an input they will get the
optional ID and the user's actions so we
looked at our application or at our
architecture and we divided it into
three layers day time domain and the UI
layer when I started to go one step
further and be a bit more opinionated in
the way we're using that the or in the
libraries that were using so we knew
that the live day time really shines
when it's used together with an activity
or a fragment so we decided to really
keep the live data only between the view
model and the UI and that's it and even
more because of the nice integration
between live data and data binding we
decided to also use data binding in our
XML but again still with all these
constraints and all of these guidelines
that we've set there are so many ways in
which we can actually implement this
kind of architecture and we knew that
Coughlin's and the coding language
features will help us improve this even
more and more precisely what we
particularly like are the functional
constructs that coffin supports so
actually one of the first decisions that
we have to make was how do we handle
asynchronous operations and we decided
to work with coroutines as the pretty
much backbone of our app because with
qualities it's easy to just launch a
core routine and handle the response and
more precisely what we like this the
fact that core teams have a scope so for
example let's say that you're opening
the activity you're triggering a network
request you want to make sure that when
you're pressing back and exiting that
activity
you're also cancelling that Network
request so this scope scoping of the
proteins was something that we liked so
this meant that we'll excited that in
the view model would be the place where
we're launching and we're canceling
coroutines
and we're also making that transition
between coroutines and live data but
then for all the other layers above the
view model we would just use suspension
functions but the suspension functions
would return a result
class so more precisely this result will
have two times success or error and this
is because I wanted to make sure that
we're not throwing exceptions here and
there but rather that these exceptions
those errors represent a state so what's
uh what's interesting in cotton is that
if you want to be able to extend the
class you have to mark it as open so
this means that classes are final by
default and you have to be intentional
when using inheritance so this means
that cotton really supports this idea
this best practices of a favoring
composition versus inheritance but we
can do better than using open classes we
can use a sealed class because with the
seal class we can restrict the class
here keys means that we can't extend the
class outside this file so a lot of
times when we would use this resolved
class we will typically use it inside a
when so first of all when support
smartcasts so this man that it was easy
to do when result is success if
something when resolve is error do
something else but because every time we
were using it we wanted to make sure
that we're always handling every case I
want you to make sure that if I know by
mistake were not handling something we
wanted the compiler to tell us that hey
you forgot something you forgot to
handle the error case so this month at
the one needs to be exhaustive but one
is exhaustive only when used as an
expression so we added we created the
exhaustive property so more precisely we
created an extension property on T where
we're just returning the object here's
another problem that we had so we had a
comment class and a comment with replies
so the difference between these two is
in the fact that the comment also hosts
the information about the user that
posted the comment so it will have the
display name and the portrait Arara
whereas the comment with replies is
pretty much a tree structure that holds
the
twice of the comment and the replies of
the replies and so but what we had to do
was to build a comment out of the
comment with replies and a user object
so you say okay that's easy we will just
create a new constructor that gets as
parameters the user and the comment were
replies and that's it but the thing is
that we don't really like this because
the classes were in two different layers
and why should the comments know about
the comment with replies why should it
know necessarily about the user maybe
the data comes from somewhere else why
should we need to change this this API
so what we ended up using is an
extension function so more precise will
be built an extension function to the
comment with replies that based on the
user object it would create a comment so
this when you're building an extension
function you only have access to the to
the public fields so this means that
we're not by mistake accessing or
changing any private implementation data
and it allows us to keep our classes
focused focused on what they do without
extending them so it meant that we
didn't have to change the public API and
we would avoid accessing private
implementation details so what I like
about data classes is the fact that
their value objects and this actually
shines in when used in tests so for
example we had an upvote flag in the
comment someone we'd build a test to
check whether a comment is about it it
would create our comment with the
uploaded flag to force would avoid a
comment and then we would check whether
the expected result is similar to the
comment initial comment but with that
uploaded flag to true but the thing is
that especially in our case because the
comment has so many fields it was easy
to make mistakes and it was easy to miss
what's actually important here the fact
that the avoided flag has changed with
Coughlin you can use the copy method and
there we would just create a copy of the
object and that is called on and we're
setting the flag the flag
that we're actually changing and that's
it the code ends up being more concise
and more readable more comprehensible so
let's take another example so we had
another in our app we were working with
a remote data source to post a comment
to post a comment and here we would
expose a suspension function that will
return I resolved and inside this method
we will create a new comment request
with trigger that requested the back end
we would await for the response and then
we would handle the response building
either result success or a result of
error depending on what's needed but if
you look at this code this is actually
not enough because in the case when your
device is offline this code will crash
so what we actually had to do is to wrap
every request inside a try-catch and we
have a lot of requests so we saw that we
kept on adding and adding this try-catch
everywhere and then our methods were
bolted bloated so we couldn't really
focus on what really mattered on
building of the response triggering the
request so what we did is create a
top-level function so this would be a
suspension function that would get as a
parameter a suspending lambda and the
error message so here it would just
trigger the call wrap it inside a
try-catch and then we would build in
case of an exception a result of error
based on the error message with pass 10
so that this means that in our mode data
source we could just create a safe API
call and then put the call that actually
matters for us inside another function
like this the code became more readable
more easy to understand so this safe API
call I was saying that has the call as a
first parameter and then the error
message is a second one but in Portland
if you if the last parameter of a method
is a lambda it means that you can use
this as a trailing lambda so that meant
that when you're calling this instead of
passing these two parameters we can just
pass the
our message as a parameter of the
function and then use the training I'm
the syntax to call the method so like
this the code becomes more concise but
is it really more readable so when we
looked at this it felt like what matters
here the most is the error message which
is not really the case what matters for
us a lot is that the method that gets
called is this post comment so we
decided that although the code is more
concise
it doesn't mean more readable so brevity
isn't necessarily a good thing so even
if cotton offers all of these kind of
options and features be mindful and
think whether you actually need all of
these or use them in the right places
here's another example
so as soon as we were switching to
Coughlin especially in our activities
the first thing that we did is make all
of our views late in it because we
didn't want to handle all of this Nullah
bility but then we looked again at our
code and we saw that we shouldn't do
this that some views for example are no
result views were only inflated when
specific conditions are met so actually
no ability was good no ability can be
meaningful no ability was telling us
that something is missing and we should
really handle it so overall we saw how
all of these features from coffin-like
Cortines and imitability and functions
as first-class citizens can help us
shape our app and together with a guy to
app architecture helped us build this
maintainable this safer and faster to
develop architecture that we wanted to
have thank you
[Applause]
[Music]